so my name is Tom Wickham Jones and I
work at Wolfram research my talk is
advances in the whorfin compiler and I'm
going to be talking about the latest
advances in the wolfram compiler you
know for the upcoming version earnings
and lots of interesting things to do
with compilation of the Wolfram language
so my name's Tom Wickham Jones and I
want to talk about advances in the
wolfram compiler so the wolfram compiler
it's a compiler for the Wolfram language
this is a long term project I give a
game giving a talk every Europe the
conference's that conferences about this
but I think it's really starting to
become more concrete and more more
useful but this is a long term project
and it's not finished it's entirely
built in the Wolfram language and I
think now I think there's there's over a
hundred thousand lines of code I think
this is one of the largest projects
WolframAlpha is bigger but sometimes I
tell the people that work on Wolfram
Alpha it's just the same function
written many times and the compiler is
is abstracted so we only write functions
once no it's a large Wolfram language
project one of the goals is to leverage
latest knowledge you know mathematical
scientific knowledge about compiler
technology and also use the latest
technology that's that's available as
much as possible version 1 of the
compiler was reached in Mathematica 12
and just at the moment we're just
finalizing testing to add the compiler
to the to the cloud so in this talk I'm
going to I want to introduce the
compiler some of you have come to talks
about the compiler previously some of
you are not I'm not
hopefully I won't bore the people that
have seen this before but I won't rush
over things for the people that haven't
I won't show some of the latest
advantages I want to show a new feature
that we've added to version 12.1 called
data structure that's a that's built
from the compiler I'll show a little bit
of compiler technology benefits of
working the Wolfram language and imma
show some interesting innovative
programming
patterns and techniques that you can use
of this technology so compiler basics
what's the idea convert Wolfram language
code into native machine code and this
is done with adding type annotations to
the Wolfram functions and there's an
inferencing a type inferencing system
type inferencing is a huge fascinating
topic that in a sense we're just
touching a corner of it but that's
that's that's some of the benefits of
this a lot of people they want to get
faster execution that's that's important
but there's other aspects you get a
guarantee you get some guarantees of
correctness if your code is not correct
if you're doing something that it
doesn't understand it gets rejected at a
compilation phase so what we're doing is
we're turning runtime errors which are
bad into compile time errors which also
bad but they're easier to fix because
the developer of the code sees the
compile time errors whereas the user of
the code who might not be the developer
sees the runtime errors with this you
can build features that can't be done in
in the regular Wolfram language this is
a powerful a new way to connect to
external code for him showed a nice
example of doing that you can make
special app standalone applications
target special hardware so quick basic
demonstration we have a function like a
regular lambda you know nonnamous
function in Mathematica and it has
arguments but these arguments are given
type annotations we run it in function
compile and we get back this compile
code function that you give it give it
the input and you get the answer well
very boring and let me tell you for
several years this was the only function
that we compiled and people are getting
very frustrated or come on can't you do
more than that but you know working
compilers you you build things up yes
yes anyway so that's the now what
is supported so core native types so
integers reals complexes but also we
support all the different sizes that are
also present in numeric array so this is
a nice way to work with what's what's in
numeric array
you know unsigned integer 8 bytes or you
know integer 64 or real 32 and and you
can go down to like these real 16s which
which are important for some some
machine learning operations packed
arrays so with all the tensor operations
so what's new that's not like the older
compiler is we we spoke you know
programming functions like map and fold
and stuff but we also support functions
there's a first-class object so you can
pass functions into as arguments or
return functions as results and we're
you know also you try not to be too
technical but functions that capture
other data from outside their
environment those are called closures
it's important we also provide a
callback mechanism to the wolfram
evaluator so there's a way of seeing
what's people say what's supported we
actually maintain a function that probes
the system and these are from the list
of current functions that are known in
some way to the compiler these are the
system contact symbols of course there's
lots of internal functions you know that
you know things that we that we use to
build the compiler and that's a much
bigger list right and examples actually
the dot page is the marketing pages that
Roger was talking about have some not
unuseful some quite useful interesting
examples what we don't have yet is a
nice tutorial we have a big internal
tutorial that we maintain and I think
that should be sort of broken out now
when you use function compile you get
back a compiled code function you can
execute this straight away I'm not going
into the details of how that works
it's quite interesting though you can
make other things so this is an
important output mechanism and this is
function compiled but I'm exporting into
a library on my Mac that makes a die Lib
the advantage of that is and I can load
the die lib and I get my compiled code
function that I can use you know it
works just like if I did function
compiled the advantage of this is you
don't need to run the compiler to get
the compiled code function in fact you
don't even need to have the compiler
installed on your machine it comes with
Mathematica so that's not really an
issue but that's a key benefit because
you compile it once and you can use it
many times and it's optimally fast
constant in know you can have may I'll
be showing examples that you can have if
you send it to someone with a Mac
running 12.1 it will work if you send it
to someone with a Mac running 1.0 it
won't work right but you'll you'll get
well first of all this is using library
library link this is a hybrid file so if
library link exists you'll be able to
load it but you'll get a warning telling
you about a you know a mismatch so
that's a complicated question that yeah
I want to keep going No
- excuse me hold on right so this is
symptom other output so I can generate
there's this function compiled export
string and this is generating a
generating there's this LLVM internal
code that it's this is a little bit like
an assembler or it's a little bit like c
with fixed types but it's written in
this slightly strange way that's that's
actually incredibly useful that's part
of the LLVM tools and here i've
generated assembler this is generating
assembler for my architecture but i can
generate output so here i can generate
the output for it's loading some stuff
for Windows so I could compile this for
and make an object file for Windows so
that's an object file you'd still have
to link it I can't make a library I
can't make a dll on this machine I mean
that's that's a you know there are ways
of doing that but that's not a workflow
that we've optimized you can MIT you can
compile object files for a variety of
platforms so I just did that for Windows
32 you know windows 32-bit and in fact
it's even known even though we the
function was defined okay well it's it's
written if I write it's it's made a it's
made something for Windows now here are
some of the challenges that we face in
in this and these are things that people
sometimes they just think well you know
it's not over you know well what's
what's you know what's the big deal so
I've written a function here that adds
two integers and I'm giving it an
integer that I've chosen specially I'm
adding zero to it and I get an answer
now if I call the same function
and I add this specially chosen integer
and I add one to it I actually get an
error but I get a result yet the error
sum in the stylesheet it's not but it's
saying there's integer overflow so
what's what's going on here so first of
all there was an error and and this
particular invocation defaults to using
the old evaluator so you still get a
results you can configure that sometimes
if things error out you don't want you
know you just want it to terminate but
this by default function compile doesn't
do that so what's what's going on let's
look at the signature of the function
and this is integer 64 to introduce it
the result is an integer 64 so the this
is the input to to 63 minus 1 if I
increase that so whoops yeah if I just
do this this is no longer this is the
result I was generating it's no longer a
machine integer it's over its flowed out
of the range of things so why so we've
got code that checks that you're that
you're doing that if you write a C++
program you don't get this this does not
happen so why and in fact if you want
the C++ behavior you can in compile you
can use this thing unchecked block so I
write wrap unchecked block around it and
now I get an unchecked plus so it works
in the same way like we see there so
that's that's all fine but of course if
I do the thing that overflows oh my gosh
it's gone from a positive number to a
negative number now for those of you
understand two's complement you say but
it's worse than that because in C C++
standards this operation is undefined so
actually it's not you can't even rely on
it unsigned integers you it's defined
that they wrap around but for these
integers it's it's
it's undefined and compilers this is a
common source of coding errors that
programmers make is they rely on
operations signed integer operations
wrapping around but the compiled it's
not defined behavior and the compilers
might behave differently you know the
compilers are not required to support
undefined behavior obviously so this is
some of the challenges that we face
doing this validated arithmetic is
actually surprisingly again that's an
interesting detail of compilers it's
actually surprising that it's quite fast
actually so but still that's that's that
these are choices that you have to make
right so here's another thing this is
some newer things so I I'm now I've got
a function and I'm giving it a boolean
and I'm doing you know not of the
argument and then calling the sine
function on it now if Michael trot was
here he'd tell me some algebra where
this makes perfect sense and everything
but in the sine function that the
compiler knows about doesn't know what
to do with boolean x' and we get an
error message actually so a message is
not super message make even more sense
but what you do get out of it now from
this failure object that comes back from
compile you can ask for the source of
the failure and this tells you what it
was that gave the error and these sorts
of things are quite useful here's
another example of some code that I've
written so I've got a local variable Y
and I'm initializing it but I'm
initializing it in a branch so when it
comes down to this one not always to
reach this branch has the variable Y
being initialized so when we compile
this we get an error that tells us this
and again the error is not useful but we
actually I can't show you this today but
soon it will say
why was in uninitialized but we tell us
the source and actually since we started
heading these these these are quite
useful and when you write Wolfram
language code you actually see a
surprising number of these these are
sources of error in your code right yes
the source is what it was doing that
caused the error it's this subpart of
the program that caused the error right
it doesn't when we get Brenton's tools
hooked up
it'll give more information like a line
number or something so yes so another
thing you can do could we maybe have not
too many Wolfram research questions
because I've got a lot of material to go
through and you have other opportunities
so you have like two questions each and
each right sorry you tie but yeah no of
course not
no it would be completely happy that's
that's the that's what you should do yes
right so good so it sorry you tie but I
ask you a question go on
that's a right that's that's a
complicated question because right right
okay right the answer is it depends upon
the context if you were going to use
that sine of integers with a real number
it will actually succeed to work it and
it will numerical eyes that particular
input so this is one of the things that
I've been very proud of that I think we
handle incredibly well when you mix
exact arithmetic exact quantities with
in exact things
so in technically that means it's known
to the type system but we don't provide
a implementation and there's a pass that
optimizes ease which is actually it's
quite a useful pass so this means that
we correctly we have a place in the
future if we chose to support these
things in the compiled language but we
don't get incorrect answers now so I
think that's and I talked to mark
carefully to try and make sure that I
dealt with these things in appropriate
ways so it's the same as if you put PI
or E or or mathematical constants into
the program and those are also dealt
with with with with with correctly right
another thing you can do is you can I'm
not gonna show too much but there's a
lot of options for tuning your code for
performance when you're doing this
you're trading compilation time for and
execution time you might be willing to
you know spend more time compiling if if
you're going to get faster code so we
have a bunch of Wolfram optimizations
that we've built in and then we're
sitting on top of the LLVM system and
that has another huge swath of
optimizations the Wolfram optimizations
are useful because they know about our
language LLVM does not know about our
language but but we do so we can write
special optimizations that are good for
what we are doing some other
optimizations you can do are like
turning off things so you can turn off
the validated arithmetic that can help
in some ways
a risk another thing that you can do is
that we insert code to do abort handling
so if you can do like you know command
period to abort your you can turn that
off and in some cases that can help now
if you just want to leave your code
running you don't want to abort it and
then you go off and come back you know
two days later that is is useful if
you're working and you want to run
dynamic and things like that it is bad
right by default the abort handling is
wrong these are choices that you have
and I hope we've made sensible defaults
right keep going so good now I've really
got to keep going
so new way this is a powerful new way to
call external code it's it's quite
simple so I can declare here I'm adding
to the type environment and declaring a
function and I'm saying it's known in an
external library maybe in the external
library it has a different name so we
can map and I'm giving it a type so then
I would
I'm not going to execute this spurt then
I would call the function write a
function that used it and then when I
compiled it I would add external
libraries goes to live if this is a
library that's already linked into the
Wolfram kernel you don't need to do this
external libraries but so that's quite
quite interesting right fine
it's you gain new features coming up in
12.1 so a major new feature we're
calling type product this is part of a
set of things that people would call
this algebraic data types and this is
there's another thing a type product is
like a it's like a product it's like a
strap to a record and there's another
thing which is which will be called type
sum which is like a Union and the two
things fit together quite nicely we've
implemented the first part of this and
this this has a lot of interesting
potential so here's an example
so I'm declaring a type product I've
given it a name and I'm saying it has a
field f1 that's an integer and a field F
- that's
real and then I can compile this and
this is supremely boring function that
is creating an object then pulling the
fields out and adding them really dull
but you can do more than that if you
start to add so here I'm adding some an
attribute or I'm saying implements to a
new thing and I'm saying this is
expression boxed so boxing in many
languages means that you wrap something
around it expression boxing or the type
product means I can return it to the
evaluator so let's see what that means
so here I'm creating an instance of this
you know product and then I'm writing a
function and I'm returning this when I
call this it comes back up to the the
the evaluator so so what's in this can
be anything anything I want and then I
can write other functions if the front
end it's something really nasty it's
there we go right it was really there
I've got the thing here right so now I'm
writing a function that takes one of
these things and this is getting getting
the field so I've compiled that and I
pass in the thing and because I put 10
up there I get 10 down there so I can
get right getters and setters and I can
write more complicated functions so
there's a lot more stuff to this we can
add more attributes you know that
suddenly make it do work with memory
management and such like we use this
type product this is a nice way to
create data structures and we've written
a whole bunch of these data structures
and made a slicker nicer feature for
12.1 this is the data structure feature
that Stephen showed in his talk at the
moment we've
implemented a bunch of these and I'll
just show you this one here called not
being too badly on top right this is an
ArrayList so I can so I can append so
I've appended a bunch of things to this
ArrayList I can look at the I can just
get the stuff that's in there I can get
information this is I think I've got
this Stephen wanted this and actually
it's quite nice actually
I can go to visualization visualization
is a little bit tiny but it is showing
these visualizations are quite useful
for explaining what they are and also
seeing how they are behaving so that's
the ArrayList I can get parts and I can
you Tate parts so I'm assigning to the
second part so if I come and look at the
normal now I've you know originally this
was two and now it's become F of four so
key point about data structure is its
pre-compiled we ship this in the version
the compiler a weakness of the compiler
at the moment is it's quite slow to
compile I'll talk about that but data
structure it's pre compiled into
libraries so we just ship the library
with the product and you don't you don't
run the compiler to use them it doesn't
even touch the compiler if you know to
use the built in the operations that
we've we've built in key part about data
structures many of the data structures
though not necessarily all of them they
are mutable so like this ArrayList is I
can append to it so here's a list and
I'm calling a pen too and I'm doing this
twenty thousand times and it took six
seconds I do the same operation on my
machine and it's mutating the thing now
those consequences to this
so but anyway or I can do the same thing
I cannot
date parts and that's also now in the
system in mathematical and will from
language we updating parts we have a
very complicated mechanism that tries to
look at reference counts and avoids that
but it often goes wrong and it has the
unintended consequence of making your
code suddenly it's not running in linear
time it's running in quadratic time and
this is a bad thing if you're doing a
big calculation so this this thing here
is is is useful you can start using it I
I think there's some possibility that we
could start analyzing more from code and
we could see oh you're doing a pending
loop let's lift that let's rewrite your
code automatically lift that out turn it
into an ArrayList and then turn it back
out of one and those sorts of things can
be quite quite useful maybe with some
hints or something so that's the value
of ArrayList and also we support so
here's a made an ArrayList and we
support functional operations so I can
do you know like fold or something or
you know whatever so this is just these
these functional operations fold map
whatever we want now another feature of
these is that they're built with the
compiler and they completely seamlessly
integrate with the compiler and this is
a great way to add functionality so I've
got you know someone says oh you know I
want I want reverse for my ArrayList and
you know we probably will add reverse
but supposing we hadn't added reversed
what are we going to do so we'll we'll
write it and this this implementation of
a reverse is probably how you would
write it if you didn't have reversed
you'd probably write something like this
you might well do so we can write that
it would execute at top level but we can
then compile it and now when we when we
write it you know here's here's our
thing
and it runs so that's quite nice what I
think is very exciting about this is the
way that we are writing it is the way
that users can write things so we're
breaking this gulf this barrier between
there's some secret internal way that we
write things and there's some other way
that people write things there's just
one way so everyone is a developer so
you know that's that's a good thing and
so you we can extend things and add
things and and such like so that's
that's kind of a nice nice feature so
okay here's another I'm now writing some
compiled code going back to actually
using the compiler and here I've got the
right time I've got a little program and
this is I'm creating a new ArrayList and
then I'm going to append integers into
this so the what do we what do we have
here so we create this so this is not
the sort of fancy expression ArrayList
that has this is a sort of slightly roar
type of data structure we still get this
useful way of working at it but this is
a different thing the signature of this
is this is not a Rae list of expressions
where you can put arbitrary symbolic
things in to us this is an ArrayList
that only takes integers if you try and
append a boolean or a real you would do
that in compiled code your code will not
compile so that's an important point
another aspect of this is that it means
that we can create versions of ArrayList
for specific individual types
that's called poly we only have one
implementation but we instantiate it for
different types that's that's called
polymorphism and it's a powerful way to
for things to work so now just to go
back to data structure at present in
12.1
implemented you know a bunch of things
you know a bunch of sets we have for
example a hash set so this is a set I
mean a set in the sense of a collection
of distinct objects where distinction is
computed by hashing so if they hash
differently they're different
well no no uses a hash to as a
pre-selector and then it uses the same
cue to distinguish and we have a hash
table we intend for near future means
12.1 to implement more some more things
and it's great fun you know chatting to
people I chatted to Brenton he said you
know he really likes DQ so fine let's
let's let's make a DQ because it's in
actually adding these things is quite
because we share a lot of code it's
quite easy to to to to add these some of
them they start to get a bit more you
know tries and things super useful but I
think this is this is useful I am super
interested if there anyone has
particular data structures that they may
have experienced all from other you know
talk to me and we can consider you know
we'll get them in a get them in a
pipeline right now that's keep going yes
I'm not doing too badly I can get some
more questions from more from people
turn on Wolfram people mode right
Konstantin so of which
well it depends what it depends what you
their data structure is in fact the
function pages for the data structures
describe the complexity or the sometimes
the complexities are slightly
complicated you know it's the best case
worst case you know but it it does
describe so for the for the ArrayList
it's it's some constant time to an
element lookup for a linked list
appending and prepending is constant
time but element lookup is is is order n
so yeah because it's not the same these
functions are not it doesn't have all
the functionality of the built-in
function I the current think he is not
to do that cuz it doesn't have all of
the functionality and arguments and
things of the things so right yep yes
well the Association Association I mean
you're asking an internal question about
I I think it's look again the hash-table
in the kernel is well it's this sort of
pseudo complicated polymorphic so it
depends what it's instantiated for for
the similar things it might be better
because these things here are
instantiated for particular types
whereas the one in the kernel is some
pseudo object-oriented void star
function technique which has fewer
opportunities for inlining if we rewrote
the internal one in templates then then
they might be more similar but you know
I'm not sure that we need to do that yes
yes yeah that's the nice thing about
developing our own compiler is we can we
can we fix that we study things and we
fix them and we spend a lot of time
looking at other languages you know how
does rust do this you know oh yeah
they're doing that so we shouldn't feel
bad about doing that or that's a good
idea or oh they're not we're better than
them so you know but it's it's important
to study these things right now I'm
gonna switch gear from data structure
and look at some internals of the
compiler again I'm going to be you know
somewhat brief and right so we have we
have a pipeline so we start out with
Wolfram language Wolfram language code
and we sort of operate on it with you
know a macro system we then turn it into
this sort of internal you know an
alternative way of looking at programs
that's suitable for compilation that
I'll talk about a little bit
we are type inference we do type
inferencing we do more transformations
and optimizations and then we generate
executables yes the last one is not what
everything else is done is everything
else is done with Wolfram language code
the last step is done by LLVM yeah we we
have a we have a wool show won't I'll
show some of this so right so so this is
the sort of pipeline that we go through
and we make this modular pipeline where
we run transformation passes on the
individual you know on the individual
thing and it's a great opportunity for
abstraction and one of the philosophies
that we have is rather than having a
pass be super complicated to do lots of
things if there's a common thing in it
we lift that out and we put it in
another pass so these parties are often
very simple and you know sometimes you
run a pass and then you have to fix up
the types so rather than having you know
ten passes each of which fix up the
types individually we we just run the
type fix up pass after each one of these
and this philosophy is super useful
because it means we can improve the way
we fix up types without having to go to
ten different places and and you know
sort of in and improve all of them so we
have a lot of these passes and you know
some some of these if people have graph
theory background there's tons of graph
theory in in this and you know
optimizations you know and things you
know sorts of things here's a pass the
inserts code to deal with a BOTS and you
know here's you know optimizations etc
like that there's about 200 of these so
we don't run all of those all the time
an interesting idea sometime is to use
machine machine learning to try to
figure out some optimal stream of
optimization passes so we haven't done
that yet so LLVM Wolfram compiler uses
LLVM as a back-end so what is LLVM LLVM
is a compiler infrastructure that is
developed from initially a a sort of
pedagogical tool down the road here you
have AI into what is now a large
collection of compilers and for working
with different input languages and
different output targets so the thing
that's nice about it it has a very nice
architecture that you can learn from
because it's a set of reusable
components and it's well designed for
extension it has this well-defined
intermediate representation that I was
showing you and that's similar to the
representation that we use a lot of
people they've heard of LLVM some people
especially if they do C++ development on
the Mac they use they've heard of clang
so clangs the compiler that you get on
Macs so clang is built from LLVM you can
run clang on on Linux machines you can
run clang on on Windows and in fact
Microsoft of what's what's happening now
is a lot of companies like Microsoft are
starting to incorporate these tools into
their into their systems
there's a lot of tools that work with
LLVM things like debuggers and code
transformers profilers and want one
thing that's super interesting is that
now a lot of people when they're working
with you know exotic hardware's you know
this web assembly thing which is this
weird assembler code that lives in web
browsers or GPUs GPUs have been around
for a long time but now most GPU know
certainly the Nvidia tools or all they
just use ello
vn because they have a nice architecture
that they can fit into and they don't
have you know they don't have to
reinvent many things f gpa's so it's
another emerging technology which you
know is very LLVM dependent the super
exciting thing for us answer your
question I'll just make a quick point
super exciting thing for us is that
since LLVM works with these things that
means we were we have the potential to
work with all these things and we've
done some work not quite finished we
were trying to get some GPU
functionality of just literally writing
like a cuda map where you write your
function you know not not writing in
CUDA but writing your function and
making a program that will then go to
run on the GPU we did it's you know GP
even with the help from our compiler
when we've done the work with our
compiler it'll be very easy but while
we're building that it's it's it's quite
challenging to make such things I think
that's super interesting maybe next year
will will will will show some some some
examples of that was that your question
oh sorry go ahead excuse me the which
AMD GPUs right so
well if but for the CUDA ones that's
that's quite because that you can run
CUDA GPUs on many Pat on you know
different platforms and they are you
know that you know you can build CUDA
programs on Windows or Mac or or Linux
so it is a bit more a bit broader yes
well the AMD thinks if there's an LLVM
solution for it it's quite
straightforward if there is not an LLVM
solution for it it's not impossible but
it's it's much more work well I'm not
saying it's not a priority but I'm gonna
work on the you know I mean first of all
when video GPUs are very dominant okay
you know our machine learning
functionality that's yeah so but that's
that's that's what we're going to focus
on is the you know the common things
that are easy to work on so right I'll
keep going right so she's talking about
LLVM type framework I'm not going to
this is also super interesting I'm not
going to talk about this this a whole
lot other than say it provides it's
static typing you do a typing pass at
code processing time it provides
inferencing so you don't there's a
minimum amount of type annotations
typically you add type annotations at
the entrance to your function um it
supports parametric polymorphism without
going into the details of that the
benefits you saw with the ArrayList um
another detail of the type framework is
it's independent of the compiler so the
compiler uses the time framework type
framework but they there
separate separate elements and so all
these names of types and things as far
as the type framework goes it you know
has no knowledge that what's the
difference in an integer and a boolean I
mean it just couldn't care less it's
only important when you actually make a
concrete implementation and you write
have some actual code that that that
these names mean something right so
right so developing Pilar in the Wolfram
language compilers are not small trivial
things but there's some great advantages
to working in the Wolfram language and
the other thing is you know building it
in the Wolfram language that's a great
way to integrate that into our system
and to get real benefits so what are
some some things that we have here so
these are real things that we really do
so we need to visualize like quite often
writing some code and something goes
wrong with it
so the code is generated into this sort
of output form that we can verify it has
like nice verification properties and
that that make make make makes it work
very nicely but still just knowing that
something's broken you have to figure
out where it went wrong that can be a
bit challenging so I've got a program
here it's got a branch and a loop so
what's you know and I can see the code
there but that can be a bit daunting
sometimes what's quite useful is to see
a control flow graph so in this control
flow graph I can print it like that or
actually in this talk it's better to
write it oriented a little bit
differently it's the same it's the same
graph and so just to run through this we
can we have a start and then there's a
branch and the branch goes into two
nodes and then it goes it goes into this
loop goes around this loop and
and it ends at the end yes it's kind of
isomorphic with it it's an ssa if you're
familiar with what I mean by SSA it's an
SSA form it's very similar to it's not
exactly the same they have we have
slightly different instructions in in
the IR but it's it's it's SSA forever it
stands for single static assignment and
you break has several properties you
have blocks of code where you you know
it breaks it into a control flow graph
the block of code you enter at the top
exit at the bottom and you have
variables that only are only ever
assigned to once a super interesting
thing and this will really bore most of
you here but is that you can fold the
SSA inside out into a lambda into a
sequence of lambda functions and
actually it's those interesting
discussions about which form SSA form is
suitable or you can also compile a
lambda X you know a lambda version and
that's but we work with LLVM and
actually for the language that will I
think an SSA form is is useful the SSA
property is very is it's fantastic
because it's it's very flexible and easy
to work with and it's very easy to
detect and it's very easy to prove that
it's conforming and that's that that
makes this whole thing work correctly so
that's that's now I'm just a here's our
more
this is yeah he's more bigger example so
I've got a table with two iterators you
know again the code it gets gets a
little bit big and bulky and then when
you add memory management code it gets
even bigger and bulkier but these
control flow graphs it quite they're
quite useful you can spot this you can
see where if if something's got broken
in the you know like you can't reach the
end from the beginning then because some
some optimization part
I went a bit wrong and it deleted some
link that's that's wrong or it made a
graph where there was a back edge going
to the wrong place that's that that
would be bad and you can spot potential
for optimizations because you can start
eliminating jumps and in microprocessors
it's good to have you know you know well
it depends what your goals are you know
if you have a gigahertz processor that's
lots of instructions but you can start
eliminating jumps then then that can be
advantageous for your for your code so
that's the control flow graph it's
fantastic in Wolfram language I want to
do you know I want to plot a graph well
hey I just call graph plot isn't that
you know I don't have to go and go to
some other tool now you know that's
that's that's that's that's that's
pretty useful here's another
visualization that we also use so this
is a different view into the code each
of these visualizations is a little bit
like an abstraction you're lifting
information you're lifting something out
of the code that you have to get some
some some benefit some insight throw
away the details you don't care about
focus on what you do care about so often
we need information about loops so the
aborting code doesn't add the bought
points at every instruction it just adds
the bought points at the entrance to
loops so we need to know what what undos
plenty of other things need to know what
the entrance to a loop is well hey guess
guess what we have a pass that does this
I've got I've got some code here that
has lots of loops and I run the pass on
it that computes the loop information
and I'm not gonna print the IR out
because it's a little bit tedious but
what I do get out is I get this loop
information this this is also returning
another data structure that we use to
create the compiler that we'll be
folding back into the data structure
thing so this says that from the root
there are three elements at the top
there's the start and the end but
there's also a loop in the middle and
then you can drill down in in this loop
that reaches other loops so you know
that you know the the children of
something are either a basic block or
it's the beginning of a loop so this is
super useful and we wrote a visualizer
for this that gives us some some
insights so there are three loops so
there's like three one two three heads
for these loops so having this parsing
things we can visualize it and
understand it that I are for this is you
know it's quite it's quite lengthy let
me just point out even though there's
lots if I are each line of I are is
maybe one CPU instruction and so it
doesn't take a long time to execute that
some of these CPU ins you know sort of
get get removed of course so that's
that's that's kind of a useful thing and
using this it means that the compiled
code that we generate actually aborts
better because we do this automatically
it aborts better than the built in you
know MC code that people write by hand
so it's quite good doing things
automatically
so anyway oh I don't have a lot of time
left and I've come to the best part of
my talk sorry about that
right I've been talking too much right
so this is annoying I have to talk about
iterators little animation here right so
this is iterators are a useful thing at
least for container data structures and
what they do is they read elements at a
time passing them up to something else
and this is a great way of abstracting
working on you know a great great great
opportunity for abstraction so I wrote
some tall so this is a package of staff
and I'm sort of instantiating a bunch of
functions that do things and so I'm
instantiating an ArrayList of integers
and some other things so we so I've got
an ArrayList and I'm appending a bunch
of stuff to it and I can see here are
the elements so in addition to this I'm
going to have some iterators so why are
these important because a lot of real
operations things like that we build
internally things like map and select
ready written in a particular way so
here's his select so what we do is we
take an expression and then we we start
we make a we make an iterator out of it
maybe it's a for loop or something we
make a stream that returns the elements
we pass that to a function that you know
applies a predicate and the ones that
pass the predicate we pass on up and
then we collect those back into the
expression this is how select works so
why is working with iterate is useful so
if we're doing two of these select
operations one after another then we're
creating a stream selecting operations
turning it back into an expression but
what are we doing here we're doing
creating another stream selecting items
and coming back so you know great
optimization get rid of you have
adjacent streaming things get rid of
them so here we have streaming selecting
from streaming so and then in fact if
you have knowledge about the nature of
the function the predicate function like
it doesn't have side effects which you
do in a compiler because you know you
can study your code and you can answer
questions about it you can even compose
these functions you could reorder them
supposing one of the functions got rid
of lots of things and the other one
didn't you might want to run the
selector that got rid of lots of things
first or one was more expensive you
could have some some ideas based upon
what they do so you might even have an
infinite stream and you could do
selecting on it and then from it or it
could be a quasi infinite stream
quasi infinite stream is a big is a big
one right fine so infinite iterator or
we've got like a video stream type of
thing now so I wrote these things so
these tools and this creates things
automatically from the so I have an
ArrayList and I've made an iterator and
the iterator just has has it got a next
function and give me the next function
so I can now I can put this into a loop
so I've just cycled through and it's
printing the output so I have ArrayList
stream and I'm printing it now I'm
taking those ArrayList streams and I'm
making a select iterator and there's the
predicate and I do the same thing and
here so now when I run this it just
shows me the even ones the odd ones
failed the predicate they didn't get
passed up and this is why this is this
is what I'm kind of doing there and
actually since I wrote this I thought
you know maybe we should just have
create iterator
and pass in a functional thing and this
would be completely this would fit very
naturally into into this this system of
course this select could be any function
and it would run super fast okay because
this is compiled code then I can nest
these things in again so I've got one
selector and it's going into another one
so this has a different a different
predicate and so now when I do the
running through the stream it filters
out the even ones it filters out the
ones divisible by three and this is what
gets gets you know sort of returned up
so here's another source of iterators
and this is a combinatory one so this is
one that returns
permutations but it returns permutations
one at a time so here's the I'm just
showing this with some simple thing
so there's another permutation and give
me the next permutation and if we have a
look at this so this is we've we've you
know per muted the thing and I can cycle
through all the permutations I can also
slightly bigger one and I wrote a
function that sits again on top of this
and this is just a counting aggregator
so so again this counter is polymorphic
it's just getting a stream and it's
counting the things that come up until
the stream has closed so that's that's
that's that's another useful sort of
chain for this so this is saying that
there are counted seven hundred and
twenty and six factorial it should be
seven hundred and twenty so so with this
I actually worked on permutations of 13
so the built-in function generates
everything it couldn't do that it would
take over 600 gigabytes but I was able
to cycle through them and correctly
count them in 20 minutes and here nearly
finished so here I've got and I've got a
list of 65 so there are a very large
number of permutations in this it's more
than the number of particles in the
universe but I can so there where I've
computed the first permutation so I've
switched switched those and I can keep
on keep on going I started to walk
another combinatorial thing subsets and
so on it's kind of nice to be able so
these are what I'd call quasi infinite
iterators so I think I'm coming to the
end probably running off a toe area
another talk sorry about right ah so I
gave an introduction to the compiler and
looked at some of the basic features and
then I started looking at some of the
new features for 12.1 type product way
to create structures and actual data
structures that we've created and built
in well
be built into 12.1 so useful aspects for
programming useful teaching data
structure courses etc I looked at some
of the internals of the compiler and
looked at how in my opinion both
language is perfect for compiler work
and then I looked at some interesting
programming ideas for working with
iterators that might be good for data
processing you know you're reading stuff
from the database and then you need to
aggregate things and do things in some
super optimized way or for combinatorial
combinations and that's it thanks very
much
[Applause]